[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight looking back January of
2017 seems like another age so much has
happened in the years since then but in
other ways not that much has changed at
all Donald Trump had not even taken the
oath of office yet but by the first week
of the new year of 2017 in case you
don't remember permanent Washington had
already committed to destroying his
presidency and Trump seemed to know it a
little after 8:00 p.m. on the night of
January 3rd 2017 the president-elect
wrote a tweet he took a veiled dig at US
intelligence agencies for their handling
of the then newly initiated Russia
investigation it pretty much the same
moment Senator Chuck Schumer of New York
was arriving at MSNBC's midtown
Manhattan Studios he went to the set and
the anchor of the show he was on that
night Rachel Maddow pulled up Trump's
tweet on a screen live on TV and asked
chuck schumer to comment on that tweet
now sure hadn't seen the tweet before of
course he couldn't have known it was
coming for one of the most calculating
politicians in Washington it was a rare
unscripted moment and so for the first
time in a long time Chuck Schumer just
went with the unvarnished truth watch
what he said think so in a day you take
on the intelligence community they have
six ways from Sunday at getting back at
you so even for a practical supposedly
hard-nosed businessman he's being really
dumb to do this so Schumer went on to
say he didn't know exactly what the spy
agencies would do to Donald Trump as
punishment for being dumb enough to
criticize them in public but he warned
and this is a verbatim quote from what I
am told they are very upset about how he
has treated them and talked about them
in quote very upset got it there's no
mistaking what that was that's a threat
issued on live television with grave
seriousness by a politician who's been
in Washington long enough to know that
it's absolutely real
in the end Donald Trump ignored it or
more likely he decided to defy it day
after day he gave the finger to the
permanent Washington establishment off
and on
sometimes at press conferences but
always with unmistakable relish trve
acted like a man who'd won an election
in a democratic country he seemed to
feel free to say exactly what he really
thought he didn't appear to believe that
the intelligence agencies had veto power
over his agenda in a thousand different
ways the new President refused to bow
and for that crime more than any other
crime he was punished most recently by
the manufactured Ukraine scandal the
Intel world meanwhile has become
increasingly defiant just yesterday
former CIA director John Brennan
expressed outrage that anyone would dare
impose oversight on the intelligence
agencies that secretly oversee our lives
I'm supposedly going to be interviewed
by mr. doar as part of this non
investigation I remember William Barr
you know when he was testify in front of
Congress he said he he didn't understand
the predication
of the counterintelligence investigation
that was launched into Russia's
interference in 2016 election I don't
understand the predication of this
worldwide effort to try to uncover dirt
either real or imagined that would
discredit that investigation in 2016 and
into Russian interference John Brennan
is a naked partisan he's a liar he's
acted in ways that would have shocked
and horrified previous CI directors and
that's saying a lot
but John Brennan is not ashamed far from
it he's proud and so are has many
acolytes in Washington Phil Mudd is a
former CIA employee like so many
partisans from intelligence world he's
now a contributor at CNN last night Mudd
sent an on-air warning to the president
and his lawyer back off or prepare to
get hurt I spent a lot of time in
government there are State Department
officials who will testify Intel guys
DoD Department of Defense people all of
us are sort of a brotherhood and
sisterhood Rudy Giuliani parachutes in
from Mars the people who will testify
are going to look at him including State
Department officials and say I don't
have to protect that guy he didn't
operate by the rules he didn't do what
you're supposed to do in government I
suspect he's worried about what the
Congress will do if I were him I'd be
worried about whether people in
government stick a shiv in his back he's
in trouble
so it's a brotherhood says Phil Mudd
this yeah a brotherhood that will stab
you to death if you disobey what Phil
Mudd is describing is not a conventional
government agency it's nothing like what
most of us imagine when we think what
Washington is doing on our behalf the
CIA of John Brennan and Phil Mudd does
not exist for our benefit it exists
solely for the benefit of the people who
work there we pay for the whole thing
but they do what they want and they
punish anyone who criticizes them they
brag about that
now that's scary of course it's a
perversion of democracy it's exactly
what the people who created the CIA
feared most but it's also if we're gonna
be honest it's annoying because for all
of the height the CIA in the end isn't
even very good at its job now remember
this is an Intelligence Agency so it's
fair to judge their performance against
whether or not they predicted crucial
events over the past 70 years and again
and again
they didn't the CIA for example was
shocked by the Korean War
it didn't predict the Soviet atomic bomb
not a small thing it missed the Cuban
Missile Crisis in the 1973 arab-israeli
war it spent decades trying to bring
down Fidel Castro to kill Fidel Castro
so naturally his regime never fell
Castro lived into his 90s meaning all
the CIA spent decades propping up the
Shah of Iran so naturally he tumbled
from power they didn't even provide a
warning before that happened because
they had no idea it was going to happen
when the Iron Curtain finally fell in
1989 the CIA was completely blindsided
by it they thought they had just
predicted in fact the Soviet Union was
as strong as ever and things didn't get
better after that the CIA had no idea
that Saddam Hussein planned to invade
Kuwait the next year in 1990 they were
totally surprised by India's atomic bomb
test eight years later by 2003 they were
totally confident that Iraq had weapons
of mass destruction in fact their
biggest success in the past 50 years may
have been creating the Taliban if John
Brennan had been working for a
non-profit business there would have
been a shareholder revolt a long time
ago and probably criminal charges he
would have been john delorean but
because it's a secretive government
see the CIA has not been restrained in
fact it's only become more powerful and
more autonomous powerful enough to take
down a president we'll see one reason
that permanent Washington is so powerful
of course so resistant to change your
oversight is that it makes alliances
with some of the least impressive but
most ambitious members of Congress just
days ago for example House Intelligence
Chairman Adam Schiff claimed his office
had no content whatsoever with the CIA
whistleblower first off have you heard
from the whistleblower are you do you
want to hear from the whistleblower we
have not spoken directly with the
whistleblower we would like to shift
also claims to know nothing about what
was in the whistleblowers complaint
before it came out but yesterday the New
York Times revealed that both those
claims relize Schiff apologized in a way
saying that he quote should have been
much more clear right Schiff now admits
his office spoke to the whistleblower
who by the way we learned tonight is a
registered Democrat but insists his
office did nothing to shape the
complaint itself but why would we
believe that at this stage